all right Tim
Tim where'd you grow up where are you
from originally I mean originally
I was born in New York on vacation
um
I grew up in the San Fernando Valley
basically my parents were upper middle
class
my mom was a pastor
my dad had
he had the thought that anything in his
pocket was his so he just spent it
uh he owns restaurants and clubs and
different
All That Jazz he liked the showboat hmm
how would you describe your childhood
um my childhood was okay
I got everything I needed and most of
what I wanted
um
but my grandfather always instilled
uh ethic into me
always work for what you get and
anything anything that comes any good in
life that comes to you comes at a price
no matter what it is there's always a
price on everything
so I mean it was pretty good I worked
I worked in
and my grandfather's business my parents
business all through kit childhood
how far are you in school
um I signed I went into 10th grade and
signed out of it
just signed in went to college
graduated by the time I was 17. from
college yes where'd you go to school UT
University of Texas oh did my graduate
work at SC
what kind of work did you do as an adult
I mean I I've
I'm an executive chef
um
I've always done cooking and
a lot of advocate work
um it's funny because I did a lot of
advocate work in one of my pet pets for
his homelessness and
turns out here I am
but
it's been a long long road
I started when I was early I was out on
the streets when I was 15.
uh basically I opened my first business
and when I was 13 with a friend of mine
how were you on the streets at such a
young age but going to college
just parents I didn't live at home
and I went out in the streets and just
your parents paid for your schooling
I paid for it I like I said my
grandfather instilled the work ethic and
I I started my first business at 13.
and it paid through everything I did
I was either
I'm I'm on both sides of the
I'm kind of a walking contradiction
um
I'm either doing real well or real bad
it's always to the extreme
my whole life's been to the extremes
you told me you've done some prison time
yeah
quite a lot of bit tell me about that
someone molested my kid
four people did
and I kind of got crazy
I snapped
I killed three people
and when I have to look for us
I was trying to go out of suicide by
cops I didn't see no reason to live
anymore
I taught that LAPD
into gunfires
I
I got lucky I guess
after six months of this
and chasing the fourth one down
and taunting LAPD it just
it got crazy
so you got you got away with it for a
while
for a long while until I turned myself
in
uh
we have a family friend that's uh very
high up in the judicial
um in the in the Senate
and she just she told my mom
they're gonna kill him
you need to get him
get them in and they're going to kill
him
at that point I didn't really care
I mean I went through life with a lot of
hard things
I lost my first wife and two kids to a
car accident
that was in front of me
and every time I go to sleep I have that
I have that dreams or that nightmare
whatever you call it whatever you want
to call it
and
my whole life is just
been running away from it
I've been real heavily in the drugs
uh living on the streets
and I live well
it sounds funny but I live well for
being on the streets
I mean
foreign
it's like I've always wanted the better
things in life
and I've stayed with them
even though I don't have a place to live
or I live out of a tent or
to the next the next place
I've always been content with it
I guess because I have survivor's guilds
how did you kill the
before the three or four men I threw one
off a third story balcony in front of
Swat
and
I shot the other two or one I
electrocuted
until he told me why he did it
and then I shot him what did he tell you
he told me because I have everything
because at the time
I had two kids
I had kids I had the jobs
I worked for a big management management
company in Rock Band management
I was a chef for them
I made it I made a meal to a year
I had everything
I just
lose it in a Split Second
your whole world changes
by your outlook
and after that nothing matters anymore
this year has probably been
the hardest year of my life
I've lost 12 family members and three
children
I haven't really cared about anything
too much this last past year
I dug myself in the Hall of drugs
I just started grieving for my children
how long were you in prison
off and on 27 years
for the murders
uh for that and drugs
[Music]
it seems like every time something's
been there
to better my life I just
self-destructing myself
we could all
think of reasons why or anything but
I've always had a high self-esteem of
myself but
overall if we really want to do
something we do it there's nothing that
stands in our way
because I know
I can do anything I want
because this is the most powerful thing
in the world it's your mind
as long as you believe you therefore do
you think there's something
in your mind that makes you
self-sabotage
it's probably guilt is still living
I always thought it should have been me
that died not my kids
I guess it's the kind of survivor's
guilt
I don't know
I know it just
okay by day as I find out myself
figure out who I am more and more
I've it gets easier and easier
now it's more of
now more than drugs it's more adrenaline
junky
the drugs don't even get me high anymore
but the adrenaline junky stuff does what
do you do for to uh for your adrenaline
now oh man rob still whatever
the crazier the better
um
from stealing cars the high-speed
Pursuits to
whatever to walking in grabbing
something and walking out
you know walking up to a into a
restaurant and grabbing a plate of food
and eating it on the way out while
waving to the maitre d
you know just different things
I could tell you some wild stories about
things that
like I said it's sometimes out of a
movie you're not worried about spending
more time in
jail or prison uh all of them are past
statue of limitations
and the one things I've talked about
I've already done time for
you know what I'm talking about like
your adrenaline
fixes
all your adrenaline
Pursuits aren't going to put you back in
jail
they could but
you know it doesn't matter
when you're
when you're a junkie like that
adrenaline junkie like that it doesn't
matter you just do it for the high
were you anything like this before your
daughter was a daughter or son that was
killed daughters daughters
two of them
the total five
I've had
My Two Front my wife and first two kids
died in a car accident right
then I had three children die this last
past year one in Afghanistan
um one in a car accident and one of the
liquor store robbery gone bad
she walked into a robbery and
took three to the chest and two to the
Head
while she was talking on the phone with
me
everyone close to you
yeah he's like
my second wife died of cancer
it's like everywhere I turn
I have to deal with death
and a lot of the way I deal with that is
drugs
what is your drug now
Fentanyl
how old are you
54 years old
spent more than half my life in jail
but in all those years in a cell
teach you how to change you
I mean they teach you a lot they teach
you about yourself if you're really
looking
because all you have to do really is
is look
because there's no time for anything
else
I mean yeah you play cards you [ __ ]
with everybody else but
a lot of alone time there a lot of me
time
and you either use it for a reason or
you just waste your time
and I chose to use it and figure out who
I am and what I'm about
you know and I have a pretty good clear
picture of it
and
I learned why I do the things I do
it's like sun twos
about you know an artist seduction and
Art of War
you know you get
you figure out how to manipulate the
next person and doing the things you
want them to do
without them knowing with them thinking
it's them figuring it out
and
I've learned myself
I've learned who I am
why I do the things I do
and it's not at all pretty some at some
of the times
but I've kind of accept a lot of it
because it's who I am there's nothing I
can do to change it
and if I worry about it then
it just ruins the rest of it
were you a different man before
say before your first marriage
I owned my first restaurant at 14.
I worked my ass off
through my childhood
and
I thought I was gonna
be one of the bigger ones in life
now I'm just a ghetto ghetto fabulous
you know
I dress well most of the time
I eat well most of the time and I do a
lot of drugs most of the time
I have a lot of women all the time
you know
but there's those times that you just
kind of cave in within yourself
and
you just go off into your own world
you might spend a week or two out there
and
snap out of it and
move on
and I've never worried about money it's
always been there when I needed it
what's your biggest fear now
growing old alone
that's probably my biggest fear
I don't
I hate being alone
I could be in a
room of 100 people and I'm still alone
I feel
and nowadays
everybody's about themselves
they stab each other in the back and
steal from each other
and think they're gonna make money and
come up when they can't do that stealing
from each other
everybody needs to help each other
or it's just a waste of time
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
foreign
we can answer
because if we would have done it
differently we would have done it then
you know
ing what I know now it's a whole lot of
things
but if you put me in the same spot in
the same position I'm going to make the
same choices
[Music]
I mean our lives are built on patterns
you know we're we're a cultural pattern
so we do the same things you know
history repeats itself all the time
so it should tell you the answer right
there
what's your biggest regret
not spending time with my kids
choosing drugs and and that way of life
over my kids
not having that Joy
when did drugs come into your life
I've been a biker my whole life and I've
been it's been around me drugs
and I've watched
cook some methamphetamine
when I was a kid
I did my first kit my first cook at six
and
just went on from there
you know even though I didn't do them
the chemicals and the high the chemicals
that were always around
and the hive from those chemicals
now that's the best high you ever have
do you have any friends
very few lefts
yeah everybody calls everybody their
friend and they're not they're just
acquaintances
uh
I have a couple
I view as my friends
that's about it
what gives your life meaning now
that all this has passed and
you're in this situation
that's my problems right now it doesn't
have any meaning
I'm just coming out I'm just starting to
grieve from my children it's just
it's just now all coming into
my head
right now I'm just living for the next
High
what was your favorite memory in your
life
it's hard that's probably my first kid's
birth
my first one is in my last ones
which is a casting memory in my life
tell me about survivor's guilt that's
certainly you can rationalize that it
wasn't your fault but
I understand that you can
think till you're blue in the face
but when you think you're you know when
you think that guilt's there it's there
it doesn't matter how clear-cut it is
that it's not your fault
when you feel it you feel it there's
nothing nothing is gonna change that
nothing's going nobody's gonna tell you
different
it's just always going to be there and
you beat yourself up constantly over it
is that the biggest emotion that you
deal with now at this point
um
biggest emotion I'm dealing with to
accepting my three kids dying
that was hard I think that was the
hardest hit I've ever taken in my life
and I've kept it all in for the last
year
I've only cried once for it twice now
but once for it I cried for 24 hours
almost
those Motel people how they hated me the
bed was salt
and I had that much liquid in me
did you like so many five kids
five kids
they're two wives
yes
well I knew a car accident went to
cancer
that was one of the hardest things I
watched too
I watched her for two years Revel up
after everything you've been through
what have you learned
about life
it certainly sucks a lot of the time
is there any unique perspective you have
on I mean life life is what we make it
really
I mean
or not any better than the next man's
we might think we are we might be better
equipped for some things and not for
others
but in the end we need to find those
people that fill our gaps
so it's always the happiest time in the
life
is with that person's
with your kids
with their real friends
um
I just think this world's [ __ ] up
right now and they're too selfish
nobody knows which way is left and which
way is right
and they blame everybody else for their
problems instead of looking in the
mirror
because in the end that's
the only person you have to blame
everything else is just garbage it's all
yeah blaming others is not gonna
fix anything
yeah
no it's never in the Palm too we need to
start figuring out Solutions not
problems we have enough of those
you've gotten used to living on the
streets
yeah
yeah I have
um
I just didn't rough this last month
but
taking a lot of hits
a lot of people still stolen a lot of
things from me
and
I can't seem to get up on top of it
but it's starting to get a little
clearer
and a little better
so we shall see
you think you'll spend the rest of your
life on the streets or you think you'll
get back into
I mean you're on
I'll get back into my home
into my way of life
it's just that
recovering from all your setbacks yeah
and I've never taken advantage of all
these things that the government's at
because I just
it's just from other people giving you
know taxes all that [ __ ] that just never
really felt like I deserved it
and then someone frauded my Edd and
every time I clear that up to get it
back it comes back the frog one
so it's like it looks like I'm not gonna
get that money I need to use about to
end and
that's 40 something thousand dollars I
could use to get back on my feet and it
keeps getting frauded and frauded and
frauded
and they said and I call them up and you
sent me the fraud one again oh we won't
do that again
take off my information now and get
everything ready and here comes the card
again and it's under the fraud name
stimulus I never got because
it was under the fraud name and someone
did my taxes tried to do my taxes
it's just crazy it's one thing after
another
do you feel like
you have some Dark Cloud hanging over
you or is this just some bad luck you
had is later in your life Dark Cloud
dark sky
class wouldn't be big enough
wow definitely wouldn't be big enough
is that it was that way as a child too
no July childhood was great
I mean like I said I had most of
everything I needed most of what I
wanted
you know
I don't know I'm just putting one foot
in front of the other
and seeing where life takes me
yeah I'm not focusing too much on one
place
because who knows where that
everything's so false nowadays
you know people believe anything that's
put in front of them
I guess for the ease of just believing
it
because life is not that easy
it's simple
but it's not that easy
all right Tim thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome thank
you I wish you the best of luck out
there you too thank you